I feel like I had just naturally grew up
like very like sexual like I was
thinking a lot sexually when I was
younger too
happened
on its own
yeah I also
it could
um
I'm also bipolar so
it could have something to do with that
like early onset with like
hypersexuality as like a child it's kind
of comment
I feel like people either talk about
child sexuality in like a weird way or
they just like don't talk about it at
all right
sweetie how old are you now I'm 22. 22.
and you are supporting yourself doing
yeah the kind of work you do which is
what
um I do only fans
um I do like Dom work
I like people taking me to dinner and
paying me for that
um
I'm trying to get into like doing like
cuckold stuff
like
I want to use MetLife